Before we do more problems, let's do a quick lesson on inclined planes
because they're really a fascinating tool for making nature work for us.
Now we already know that Galileo had a lot fun rolling balls down inclined planes.
And if you remember the reason he did this was because it slowed down motion and allowed him
to make some measurements and observations that he couldn't have made with just objects in free fall.
The question though is why did rolling balls down an inclined plane slowed down their motion.
Sure it seems sort of obvious but let's analyze it.
Instead of rolling balls, let's imagine sliding blocks because the physics of rolling
is slightly more complicated than I want to get into right now.
We're zoomed in now, and here's our block and it has mass m.
And we're going to let it slide down this inclined plane.
For now, we're pretending this plane has no friction.
Remember friction is the force associated with things rubbing.
Well, let's do what we always do and draw a force diagram.
As always, weight points straight downwards and then normal force
and remember normal means perpendicular, actually points from this direction
and that's because it has to be perpendicular.
We're not allowing for any friction. Friction would point up or down the inclined plane.
We're only allowing for this normal force.
We'll up to now what we would have done was take this force
and break it into vertical and horizontal components.
It turns out that's not the best way to solve this problem because we know from experience
that this block is going to slide down the ramp.
It's not going to slide straight to the right or straight up or straight down.
It's going to slide in this direction, so that's the direction we should care about.
And how do we care about a direction?
Well, instead of breaking this force down, we break the weight down.
We replace this downwards force with a force perpendicular to the surface,
which I've indicated with this little perpendicular symbol here and a force parallel,
which I've indicated with these two parallel lines.
Now, the thing that's really cool is that if this plane was inclined at an angle α,
we can do some geometry to show that this angle here inside this triangle is also equal to α.
And since this here is a right angle, we can do trigonometry.
In fact, if we want to look at the sine of this angle for example,
well that's going to equal opposite over adjacent so F parallel over mg and when we solve that
we find that F parallel is just mg times the sine of this angle.
I mean, just a similar thinking to show that F perpendicular is mg times the cosine of the angle.
Now let's think about what's going on here.
Well I know that a block on a plane like this is going to slide this way.
It won't jump off the plane, and it won't accelerate down into the plane. Okay.
So that means that in this direction the forces are all set. They're balanced.
Fn must equal F perpendicular. In fact, the only unbalanced force here is this parallel force.
And this parallel force since it's unbalanced is what's causing the acceleration.
It must be equal to ma. Well we can plug in what we know. F parallel is mg sin θ.
So this must be true and this tells me that the acceleration of an object
sliding down an inclined plane is equal to g times the sin of θ.
Now that's very amazing. This number sine of θ is always between 0 and 1.
It's always going to make g smaller.
So this is exactly why Galileo chose inclined planes, they slow down acceleration.
They make it smaller than g. Now, this was a lot of material.
If you have any questions, go to the forums and ask.
Now we're going to move on to a couple more problems as I have promised.